[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: The term
multiplayer games
is wide and varied.
We want to talk about very
specific types of games--
sort of put some
constraints on it.
So the types of multiplayer
games we want to talk about
are your fast-paced, online,
competitive, multiplayer games.
Right, for example,
your Overwatchs
or your Fortnites or your Rocket
Leagues-- things like that.
They have very
particular types of needs
that come down to
matchmaking and dedicated
game-server scaling that we're
going to talk about today.
And those are the
type of games that we
want to talk about today.
There is a wide variety
of multiplayer games.
But these are the
projects that we
want to talk about
today and the projects
that we both work on as well.
So some of you may be familiar
with this-- some of you
maybe not.
This is-- generally
speaking-- watched
a traditional
architecture would look
like for an online
multiplayer game.
There are a variety of ways
in which one can do this--
just so I'm clear.
This is a very prevalent
way of doing it.
That could be a whole other
talk in and of itself.
But in this
particular example, we
might have a couple of players
that want to play our game.
They're like, cool, let's play
a game, this sounds awesome.
And so they're going to connect
to some kind of matchmaker.
Now, usually a matchmaker will
look at things like your skill
level, maybe your social graph--
who your friends are-- and put
you together in a group--
so that they can pair you
together.
So they think you're going to
have a really good gameplay
experience.
Once they've got you and
put you in this group,
they're going to go talk to some
kind of game server manager,
right?
We use this term--
Dedicated Game Server--
and some of you
may not be familiar with it.
Basically, it is
a full simulation
of the game that happens
somewhere on the internet
that your players
are, therefore, going
to connect you.
This means that they can
share information about what's
happening inside the game.
The Dedicated Game Server can
tell all the players, hey,
this is what's going on.
And it also gives
us some control
in that we can place these
game servers around the world
and what sort of latency
speed we can expect.
Because we have a basic idea
of speed of light and network
speeds and good
things like that.
So this Game Server Manager's
job is basically to say,
OK, I probably have a
huge number of machines.
They're probably distributed
around the world.
And I need to say, OK, let's
go find the machine that
has some CPU resource
available and some memory,
and start up a Game
Server Process on them,
and then get that going,
and then find the port,
and then send that all the
way back down the pipe--
back down to the matchmakers.
So that those game servers
can get an IP and port--
because they're going to
connect to an individual process
on a machine.
And then those game
players will both connect
to the same IP and port
on one of those machines--
to that dedicated
Game Server instance--
so they can play
a game together.
So they're going to
share that simulation.
And this is how a lot of
games that we all play--
if people play online
games, I'm guessing you
do, because many of you here--
how a lot of them work.
But a lot of this is a lot
of the time very bespoke.
You kind of have
to do it yourself.
You have to build it yourself.
And that's hard
and a lot of work.
And I don't know--
I find it an
interesting problem,
but I'm guessing a
lot of people don't.
So what we want to
talk about today two
very particular things.
One, here, is matchmaking.
Wouldn't it be
lovely if there was
some sort of, maybe,
open-source, standardized
matchmaking framework type thing
that helped solve this problem?
And then also, here, when we
talk about this Game Server
Manager, coordinating game
servers over lots of machines.
Wouldn't it be nice
if there was some sort
of open-source, standardized
Game Server Manager type thing?
Wouldn't that be lovely?
So let's talk about
both of those.
But before we get into that,
we mentioned this a little bit
previously.
Kubernetes is at
the core of both
of the solutions we're going
to be talking about today.
And I just want to
highlight this for three
very important reasons.
Both of these projects
run on top of Kubernetes
in slightly different ways.
And we'll talk
about that in a bit.
But this is really important.
There are several reasons.
One of which is simplicity.
So usually, when talking to
game companies that run--
say-- services, such as
matchmaking, but also game
servers, they run very
different platforms for both.
Having a single platform
for both of these workloads
means that there is a
simplification of the knowledge
you need your team, the
tools you need to use,
and all that kind of stuff.
It makes that much
easier for your teams
to basically either get up
and running and also do you
day three day four
kind of operations.
I think it goes without saying--
as many of you are probably
quite knowledgeable about--
there's a huge ecosystem
of tooling here, right.
Kubernetes was not
just built by Google,
but a variety of partners
that did this work.
And there's all the tooling
that goes on around it.
Finally-- and I think
most importantly,
especially for
dedicated game servers--
sometimes you just need
to put game servers
in these kinds of
latency-sensitive applications
in weird places around the world
just because sometimes players
just show up in odd places,
and you need to put them there.
And maybe your cloud
covers it-- maybe
we have great GK
coverage there-- awesome.
But maybe sometimes we don't.
So having a standardized
platform like Kubernetes
means that you can
take your entire stack
and put it exactly
where your players need.
And that's really
important to us.
So let's [? dig ?] in.
JOSEPH HOLLEY: All
right, so we're
going to start talking a
little bit about Open Match.
This is a framework that
we co-founded last year
with Unity.
It was announced at
Unite Berlin last summer.
If you are interested
in learning more
about the founding of it and
our relationship with Unity,
I recommend you go check out
the talk on YouTube about that.
We are really focused--
in this project-- on solving
a lot of the really basic
plumbing problems
of matchmaking,
like getting players connected
to the matchmaking service,
integrating the matchmaking
service with your backend
infrastructure, but leaving
the bits in the middle--
which is your custom
matchmaking logic--
up to you, not really being
prescriptive about that at all.
So it's very flexible.
It's designed with APIs that
are horizontally scalable,
so you can handle
your player load,
even if you end up
with a really big hit.
And it's designed-- as I
said-- to integrate well
with your existing
processes or other tools
that you want to use.
It is written in Golang, but
your own, custom matchmaking
logic, you can write
in any language you
can put in a Docker container.
So how it works--
the game clients will
connect to the API
that Open Match exposes
for the frontend.
They pass in all of the
different attributes
that you might want to
try and match players on.
Developers then write these
custom matchmaking functions--
like I mentioned
before, that can
be in any language you want.
The only real
requirement is you have
to be able to package it
in a Docker container,
because this does
run on Kubernetes.
And it needs to be
able to talk to Redis,
which is the backend state
storage for Open Match.
It allows you to run a lot of
these matchmaking functions
concurrently, which is both
a way to handle scale and use
the ability that Kubernetes
has to schedule automatically
for you.
But also to enable you
to try to iterate really
rapidly on this logic piece
that is most important to you
as a game developer--
of how do I figure out
which players play together.
So let's start with a demo, and
then I'll dive in a little bit
further in a minute on
the actual architecture.
Can we switch to the demo?
That's great.
Awesome.
So what I have here is an
empty Kubernetes cluster.
Let me quickly show you
that there is nothing in it.
Also important to note upfront--
I am not very good at typing
and talking at the same time.
I'll do my best, but
I'm not great at that.
So right now, this project is
set up with a number of images.
I've already pulled them--
set them up in the project.
Most of these images
are available publicly
from the Open Match repository.
And we have a public
container registry
you can pull these from.
But you can see--
I've already got
the images there.
So the first thing I'm going to
do is just install Open Match,
and let you see what the
process of that is like.
So you can see how simple it is.
The first thing I'm going to do
is create a Kubernetes config
map.
This contains all the
configuration for Open Match.
If anyone here has actually gone
and looked at the Open Match
repository and seen what the
configuration looks like,
I am applying-- almost exactly--
the one that's in the
example on the repository.
The only difference--
you can probably
guess from the title there-- is
I turned off the debug logging.
Because that does not
make for a good demo.
So first of all, we're going to
stand up an instance of Redis.
This is just running
Redis within Kubernetes.
It is utilizing a Kubernetes
secret for its username
and password to log into Redis.
Now I'm going to
install Open Match.
This is a series of Kubernetes
deployments and services
in front of them.
It makes a few--
let me show you those.
So you can see, here, we
have six pods running.
So Redis and then five
services from Open Match--
that's the om at the
beginning of those.
These are run as deployments,
so if something were to happen,
Kubernetes will take care of
starting it back up for you.
It also allows you to very
easily scale those deployments
if you get a big hit and you
need to handle more players.
So the first thing I'm going to
do after actually standing up
Open Match is stick some
players in Open Match.
This part's going to take
just a second, because it
has to pull down the image.
I just made a brand new
cluster for this demo.
So what this particular pod
is going to do is spin up.
This pod-- just like
those other images
that I showed you
earlier-- is just
available for public on the
Open Match public registry.
But it's going to spin up.
It's going to queue
10,000 players
in Open Match seven times.
That's the seven cycles with
10,000 players per cycle.
This is just to get a
bunch of players in,
so I can actually
show you what it
looks like whenever Open Match
is doing your matching logic.
So I'll let that run.
It'll take just a second.
And then I have
a matchmaker that
is written against Open Match.
And I use that kind of
language intentionally.
Open Match is not in
itself a matchmaker.
It is a framework for
writing scalable matchmakers
on top of Kubernetes.
So this is the example
matchmaker, which
is currently on the repository.
It's not very big.
I think it's probably
220 or 250 lines of code.
Therefore, it is really basic,
but what it does allow me to do
is run a lot of concurrent
matchmaking functions.
So you can kind of see how
scaling works in Open Match.
So in general, the
approach of Open Match
is you have this very large
player population-- mine,
right now, is 70,000 people.
I'm going to try and
split up that population
into a few different
chunks and then
look within all of those chunks,
simultaneously, for matches.
So it'll allow me to
get a lot of matches
at once, without having to
chew through all of the players
in giant piles of
sequential code.
One of my deployments sometimes
takes a minute to start.
So the first loop--
I didn't give it long enough
to start off with the demo.
But you can see here.
I'm looking for two teams
of eight, four times,
in four different parts
of the player population.
You can see the pools here.
There between 10,000 and 15,000
players, roughly, per pool.
Within those pools, I'm
only looking for 16 players.
So this didn't take
very long at all.
You can see I ran all four
of those concurrently in just
a little over two seconds.
So that's not very
interesting in terms of scale.
Open Match is
definitely designed
to go a lot wider than that.
So this time, I'm
going to split it up
into 400 different
buckets that I'm
looking for players
in, and you're
going to see a lot of these go
by with, insufficient players.
That means the part of
the player population I'm
looking at-- there
literally aren't
even 16 players in that
part of the population
to make a match out of.
So what this is
demonstrating is running
400 copies of your match
logic concurrently.
This usually takes around 20
or 30 seconds to complete.
Yeah, 24 seconds.
So we ran 400 copies.
About 2/3 of those
found a match.
The other third
did not, because I
was looking at parts of the
population where there just
weren't enough players there.
You can see this got us a
lot more throughput though.
This matched 4,288
players and managed
to match about 180 players per
second that it was searching.
So that's kind of how you
achieve scale with Open Match.
So can we go back to the slides?
I'm going to briefly go
over the architecture.
And then Mark is going to
talk about using Agones
So this architecture is
basically the same diagram
that Mark showed
earlier-- only we've
taken that box that
just said matchmaker
and blown it up to show you
all the parts of Open Match.
So to begin with,
the Game Client
would talk to the
Open Match frontend.
The frontend writes the
player attributes to Redis.
Your Server Manager,
which can be anything--
maybe you have bespoke
code, maybe you're using
an off-the-shelf solution,
maybe you're using Agones--
I would recommend it--
would talk to the backend
API of Open Match.
That kicks off your
custom match logic.
Your custom match logic gets to
read and write data from Redis.
It can read and write
it directly if you need
that level of customizability.
We also offer an API
in front of Redis
to do really common matchmaking
things like filtering players
or retrieving large pools of
players from Redis at once.
The Server Manager will
then figure out which
players go on which servers.
So it'll probably
pick a server and get
the IP and port of that server.
That gets actually passed
back out, through Open Match,
to your game client app,
which at this point,
goes and connects directly
to the dedicated game server.
That's all really similar to
what Mark showed you earlier.
So this is already
an improvement.
But we still have some kind
of bespoke server management
system.
So Mark is going to talk
to us about replacing that
with Agones.
Mark?
MARK MANDEL: Awesome, so
yeah, like Joseph said,
we have this other part that
we also need to replace.
So strangely enough-- OK, so
we have another open source
project, called Agones,
for orchestrating, scaling,
and hosting your
dedicated game servers.
This has been a fun project.
We've been working on it
for actually over a year
now-- now that I think about it.
And it is built as an
extension of Kubernetes
that we'll see in a minute.
So it's basically a thing that
puts itself inside Kubernetes.
So suddenly Kubernetes
is like, awesome,
I know how game servers work.
This is actually
really important
if people aren't that familiar
with dedicated game servers.
They have this interesting
thing where they
go from stateless to stateful.
So when you don't have any
players on a game server,
no one seems to mind
if you kill them.
When you have players
on a game server,
people get really
upset if you just
ruin their gameplay experience.
They post things on Reddit.
It's awful.
No one likes that.
So Agones's real capability--
and part of its core strength--
is really managing that
transition between the two.
Now, what's really awesome
is we didn't do this alone.
Much like Joseph was talking
about with Open Match--
they built that in
collaboration with Unity.
We've been working on this
quite closely with Ubisoft
since the beginning.
It's been a really great
collaboration between us.
They've been able to bring
sort of their experience
and their knowledge around
how to run large game server
workloads.
And we have been able
to bring our knowledge
to work on Kubernetes and
open source communities.
So it's been really great.
And we've also
gotten contributions
from a wide variety of other
people since then as well.
So I'm going to
actually show you
how to do some stuff on Agones.
And here I'll actually
show you some code.
And you can actually
see how it happens.
So potentially
unsurprisingly, If you
want to start having a game
server and run it on Kubernetes
and run it on Agones, it
goes inside a container.
Nothing more special than that.
I'm sure that's something a lot
of you are very familiar with.
The only "special thing," quote
unquote, that we have is we
do have an integrated client SDK
that goes into the game server.
We have options available
in C++, Go, REST--
we actually have a
Rust one as well--
It's getting updated soon.
This is all either
GRPC-based or REST-based.
So the real short
answer here is if you
have a language
that need support,
we have an SDK for you.
I actually realized we
also have a Node.js one.
And it's not on my slide,
because it just came
in the most recent release.
And I haven't updated
the slide yet.
But Yeah if you want to
integrate it, we can do it.
And this SDK is really just
about managing game server
health lifecycle, which is
just a little bit different,
knowing whether the game server
is ready to accept players
or not, looking at
the configuration--
things like that.
Basically standard things
you need for game servers.
So I said before that Agones
is an extension of Kubernetes.
So when you've used Kubernetes--
and I think a lot of you have,
right?
You're very familiar with
services-- with deployments,
right?
You have these nouns that
exist inside Kubernetes.
Well, once you install
Agones, now this new noun,
called GameServer, is a reality.
So we can say to
Kubernetes, hey, Kubernetes,
I would really
like a game server.
I would really like to
name this game server
xonotic, which is the
example we're actually
going to use today.
It's a free-to-play,
open-source FPS.
And then we can specify things
about this game server spec
that we want to have
available to us.
So one of the things
that Agones also does
is set up that direct
port connection.
So it'll do that dynamic
port allocation for you
to set up the port that
that information is
routed to inside the
game server container.
So here, we specify
that the game
server is going to start up
port 2,600, but it's dynamic.
So it's going to give us
a port once we're done.
And finally, we're going
to say, hey, what's
my game server container?
What have I actually
put in here?
Now for those of you who are
more familiar with Kubernetes--
which many of you are-- you
have a full pod spec here.
So if you want to do
config maps, volume
mounts, multiple containers, et
cetera, et cetera, you're fine.
Now, this is great
for a single server.
In production-- in
reality, when you really
want to do this-- usually
what you want to do
is actually have a large
group of pre-spun game servers
that are sitting there
idle, waiting for players.
Sometimes game servers can
take a little while to spin up.
So much as we have pods and
deployments inside Kubernetes,
we have GameServers and Fleets.
So Fleets-- again, like we
were talking about previously--
are very aware of that change
in lifecycle between stateless
and stateful.
We'll go a little bit
into that in a minute.
But here, we have a Fleet.
It looks very much like a
deployment in that we specify
how many replicas we want.
It can be two.
It can be 2,000-- up to you.
And then, we have a template,
which is our GameServer
configuration.
And that's going to spin up
a large chunk of GameServers
for us, which is awesome.
Now the interesting question
you might have at this stage--
but Mark, you make
these direct connections
to these GameServers
by IP and port.
I don't have a load balancer.
I don't have any
of the usual tools
that I may be familiar with.
How do I get one of these
out in an atomic manner.
So we have this concept inside
Agones called an Allocation.
Basically the job
of an Allocation
is to say, hey, out of this
big group of game servers
can I please have one
atomically and set it to what
we call an allocated state?
So we know that it
has players on it.
And just do that work for me.
Do it in the right way.
Find the right place inside the
cluster, et cetera, et cetera.
So what we can do is we can
send another custom resource
definition.
Another thing called a
GameServerAllocation--
and we can say--
in this particular instance--
hey, for this particular fleet,
called xonotic, give me
one out of this pool,
hand it back to you atomically.
Just give it to me, and
send it to allocate it.
And give me its details, please.
We can do actually a lot more
with GameServerAllocation.
We've got some pretty complex
selector logic in there
if you need it.
But this is a simple example.
So once we've done that, we
can then play a game on it.
So why don't I show
you that it's action?
Can I have-- switch
over to demo, please.
Do, do, do.
Thank you very much.
Is that readable in the back?
Thumbs up?
Perfect.
Awesome.
So the first thing I'm going
to do-- much like Joseph--
we're going to install Agones.
I'm going to use Helm--
it's a package manager--
to install Agones.
You can use straight
YAML if you want.
--name=agones
--namespace=agones-system
agones/agones.
So if you're not
familiar with Helm,
Helm is a package manager for
Kubernetes to basically install
a bunch of stuff.
So that's kind of as complicated
as it is to get it up
and running.
We want to see what
we have in there.
agones-system, right?
So we have a bunch
of things in there.
There's a controller--
all sorts of stuff.
But now we have
Agones installed.
Now Kubernetes understands
what GameServers are.
And this actually runs
throughout the entire system,
which I actually think is
really, really exciting.
So I can actually say,
kubectl get gameservers.
And this is something
it now understands.
It's going to say we
don't have any yet,
but that's actually
really, really cool.
So let's create a
fleet of game servers.
We saw that xonotic
one we had previously.
So I'll just go apply -f
./examples/xonotic/fleet.yaml.
Now, everything I'm
want to do here,
I'm just going to do
through YAML files.
You may be very
familiar with this.
You could do this through
the Kubernetes API as well.
You can change one for
the other as needed.
So now I can say,
hey, get gameservers.
Let's see if those
are up and ready.
And they are.
So we can see-- here's
some information.
We have a couple of
GameServers there.
If you remember
from the example,
we asked for having two.
They're both in the state ready.
So they're actually
ready to be allocated.
We can do stuff with them.
And that's all super nice.
We can actually look at this
[? as ?] from Fleets as well.
We can see, here-- we
have two that are ready.
But two game servers
is boring, right?
That's no fun.
I mean, we're going
to get really huge,
but we can scale fleet
--replicatas=200.
Let's just say 200.
Oh, I need tell it what fleet.
There we go.
So now we can put
that up to 200.
If we want to look at that
here, we can get those details.
That's going to take a
little while to come up.
Come on, you can do
better than that.
There we go, 74.
But we actually look at
this in a different way too.
I'm going to actually
refresh this.
So we have inbuilt Grafana
dashboards and metrics
that are available.
Has that gone down in between?
Is that going to run?
Yeah, let's just rerun that?
There we go.
There we go, sweet.
So we have inbuilt metrics--
Grafana dashboards.
We can also export
to Stackdriver.
Basically everything comes out
through and through OpenCensus,
so you can send it
just about anywhere
to do all the stuff that you
need to do, as well, to manage
your game servers.
So here, we can see how
many are starting up,
how many are allocated,
how many are ready.
This is running a
little slow behind.
Usually it pings about
every 30 seconds.
There we go.
That's better.
So we've got 100--
you can't see.
That that's tiny, but you
can take my word for it.
It's about 186.
There we go.
We can see rates.
And there's a variety
of metrics that we can
take advantage of during this
We'll go back to here.
So if we look at our fleet--
all right, so we have 200 ready.
They came up pretty quick,
which is super nice.
Let's allocate one
out of this set.
create -f
Usually this would be
something you would probably
do through the API.
Your matchmaker would call this
and say, hey, can I allocate?
We might show that
a little later--
allocation-- I'm
going to go -o yaml,
so it'll return to me exactly
the results of what it's done.
So we'll do that.
I'm not going to worry
about what's up top.
I'm just going to look at here.
So here, we can see-- we've
got a particular GameServer--
awesome.
Its state has been
set to allocated.
And here are its details.
So we have an IP and a port.
So we'll do the fun thing that
everyone really wants to see.
Let's actually
play a game on here
and see if it works
over this network.
So--
JOSEPH HOLLEY:
Live demo fun time.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, exactly.
So let's run that.
I'm just going to use
that over a touch,
so that I can see this.
And let's see if I can type it.
Yeah, perfect.
Excellent.
So this is xonotic.
This is the open-source
first person shooter
that we were talking
about previously.
.230: --where are we?
What's the
dynamically-allocated port?
7162.
I'll Click Join.
The black screen
is actually good.
I don't know why.
They just made the game
to give me heart attacks.
That's just how
they like to roll.
Come on, you can
do it-- beautiful.
OK, so now I'm going to play
this on my trackpad, which
will be hilarious.
Let's see if I can find some
of the other players that
are about.
Come on.
OK, this always happens--
whenever I'm playing alone,
there's players everywhere.
And then as soon as I get
in front of an audience,
nobody's around.
There we go.
There's some bots.
So there's some rockets-- yay.
So this is me playing Agones
on a Kubernetes cluster
that's actually
running US West--
JOSEPH HOLLEY: East?
MARK MANDEL: No, West--
whichever one is closest to us.
And it's all working, right?
You can see-- I'm
playing a game.
And it's pretty awesome.
So that's cool, but I want
to show off a few more things
before we finish up this demo.
So I'm just going to close that.
We can see, here, we have one
game server that's allocated,
right?
There's a player playing on it.
Let's allocate a couple more.
I just want a few more.
And maybe at this point
in time, we're actually
like oh, you know what?
This version is not good.
Let's scale it down.
Let's get rid of it.
So let's do that.
Let's kubectl scale fleet
xonotic --replicas=0.
We're actually going
to make it zero.
Let's get rid of all of them.
Now, players-- like I mentioned
before-- players will get mad
if we kill the games
that they're playing.
So we don't want that.
So what Agones does is it's very
aware of that allocated game
server state.
So on Fleets themselves we
could do rolling updates.
We could do scale
up and scale down.
But no matter what
happens, it's always
going to say, oh,
that's allocated--
I'm not going to touch that.
So now if I look at my
fleet-- there we go.
We can see we still
have three, right?
We have those three
allocated game servers.
We're not going to touch
those until they either
self shut down or
we specifically
tell them to be deleted.
So that's one of the
big powers of Agones
is managing that workload.
Everything else on top of that--
all the utilities we provide
for GameServers-- is super
nice, but this is really
just the core of
how Agones works.
Awesome, can we go back
to the slides, please?
Excellent.
So wouldn't it be lovely
if we were friends?
JOSEPH HOLLEY: So
let's talk a little bit
about putting together
Agones and Open Match.
So for this session,
we had a matchmaker
built on Open Match that
understands and coordinates
Agones Fleets.
There is customized
matchmaking logic
that's running within Open Match
to look for compatible players.
In this case, all
it is looking for
is that the player
said that they
wanted to be part of
our GCP Next demo.
So it's not particularly
exciting matchmaking logic,
but it does show
that it is possible.
Once enough players are found--
in this case, we are looking
for a whopping two players
who want to play together--
the matchmaker will
allocate a ready GameServer
from the fleet.
And once that's
been allocated, it
will send back out, through
Open Match, the connection
details so that Open Match can
connect to the game server.
So back to the demo.
Do any of you watch
cooking shows?
Any-- a couple of you.
OK, so this may be familiar.
I have a pre-baked cluster
that I'm going to pull out
of the oven right now, so that
you don't all have to wait
for me to spin up a cluster--
sorry.
If I ran that command,
you would have to wait.
Let me switch over to that.
So basically, this is a
cluster that we made earlier.
It has plenty of CPUs.
It already has Agones
installed on it.
I'll show you briefly
what's running in it.
So in this case, you
can see it already
has Open Match installed.
This all looks really familiar
from the previous demo--
although this is a different
and slightly larger cluster.
So first of all, let's
put an Agones Fleet in it.
So in my case, my fleet
is a little bit different.
It is not running xonotic.
It is running
udp-server, which is
the most ridiculously simple UDP
server we could come up with.
All it is is a server
that takes UDP clients
and echoes timestamps to them.
Once per second, it echoes
the epoch timestamp.
So it is about as
proof-of-concept
as you can get.
Director is the name of
this particular pattern
of a matchmaker.
I'm going to stand
one of these up.
So this matchmaker
understands Agones
and is looking for a
Fleet called udp-server.
It is currently
looking at that fleet.
If I were to show
you logs from it,
all you would see is
an endless loop of,
there aren't any players,
over and over again.
So I won't show you that.
Let me actually put
some players in.
So the first thing this
does is put one player
in-- that's significantly
less than the 70,000
I did last demo.
But this is going to pay off.
Just give me a second.
So we've got one headless
client queued for matching.
Now I'm going to cue
an interactive client.
This part can take a while.
Well, it didn't.
You can see it already
got an assignment.
That came from Agones.
So the matchmaker has
already gone to Agones,
issued via the Kubernetes
API an allocate request,
gotten back the allocation
with this IP address
and the
dynamically-allocated port--
like Mark showed you earlier--
that's this
assignment right here.
And now it's waiting
for me to do something.
So I'm going to connect
to that UDP server.
As I said before, this is
not the most exciting demo,
you'll see at Next.
But it is a good
proof of concept.
So if I click Start, I am
telling that UDP server, hey,
start sending me timestamps.
So if anyone is curious what
time it is and in UTC right
now, here you go.
So we can also stop--
this has a very basic
[? rebel ?] built in.
So that unsubscribes me.
Then I can quit.
So once I quit, it has
deleted my UDP client.
That game is still running.
It still has the
other player on it.
Now I'm just going to spin
up some headless clients--
two at a time-- for a
while and watch Agones.
This is demoing something
that is also really awesome
that Agones can do for you
that is not in the demo
that Mark was
showing us earlier,
which is Agones can
do auto scaling.
So this is setup with a Fleet
autoscaler policy that says,
I want at least two available
ready servers at all times.
So every time that it
allocates all of the servers,
it will go back to
Kubernetes and start up
more GameServers for you
to keep that warm buffer he
was talking about earlier.
So this is basically just a
bunch numbers on the screen,
but you can see that
everything is working.
If I leave this up here while
I talk, you will see that--
slowly--
as my matchmaker is
pulling in players,
allocating servers
from the Fleet,
and putting players
on those servers,
the Fleet will then
go behind the scenes
and start up a couple
of more servers.
Two at a time is
what I had set for,
because when I set
it to 20 earlier,
it just shot up so fast
that you didn't see anything
in the demo-- but
the number 200,
like he showed you before--
it wasn't very exciting.
All right can we go back
to the slides, please?
Awesome.
So let's talk about
what that did.
Here, we're back to
the previous diagram--
only we've collapsed back
down that giant Open Match box
to be this nice little
stack in the corner.
So you can see we had
the players connecting
to Open Match.
They connected to
the frontend API
that we were talking
about before.
Open Match is running a
matchmaker inside of it
that understands Kubernetes.
And that's running
the custom match logic
I talked about before, looking
for these headless clients that
are tagged that they want
to play in the next demo.
As it finds those, it talks
to the Kubernetes API.
It asks for an allocation from
the fleet that reaches out
to the Agones controller.
The Agones controller
goes and grabs
a particular server, moves
that server to allocated state,
gets the IP and port
for that server,
sends that back out Open Match
to the game clients, which--
it's really hard to see on this.
But that is a green line, going
back the other way, as opposed
to the blue line we had before.
And then those players connect
directly to that dedicated game
server and play.
Now, once you've got
all of this in place,
Open Match is capable
of scaling horizontally.
If you get a really
big, hit game
and you need to handle a much
larger player base than you
expected, Agones is capable
of handling basic auto scaling
for you.
So this can
significantly cut down
the amount of
development time you
need to do around building
the nuts and bolts
part of your game backend.
So, Mark, do you want
to talk a little bit
about other features?
MARK MANDEL: Sweet, so we
showed a bunch of stuff today.
There's a lot of
work that has gone
into both of these projects.
So there's a variety of
stuff that we haven't really
talked about.
One of which, I want
to highlight again.
We sort of touched on
it previously-- both
of these projects work
across cloud providers.
There's nothing special
about the Kubernetes
that we're running
on, nothing like that.
It all uses standard Kubernetes
tooling across the board
and both of them.
Joseph did touch on this, but
there is fleet, deployment,
and node autoscaling.
Basically both projects
have the capability
to autoscale with your load.
So if you're running
in the cloud,
you have that elastic
ability to shrink and grow
as your requirements need.
Both projects have
local development tools.
So if you want your developers
to not necessarily spin up
an entire Kubernetes
cluster locally--
or they just want a lightweight
testing environment--
they both have tools
available to do that.
I showed off some of the
metrics and dashboards
that are available in Agones.
There's a whole lot
more, as well as
metrics and dashboards that
are available for Open Match
as well.
JOSEPH HOLLEY: Yeah, we
use all the same standards.
We also use OpenCensus,
Prometheus, and Grafana.
MARK MANDEL: Yep, So
it's all good stuff.
Future developments-- I'll
talk a little bit about a road
map for Agones.
We're looking to
hit 1.0 this year.
That's a big, broad statement.
That gives us lots
of room to wiggle.
I'm happy with
that, which is good.
But we have a lot more stuff.
We've been doing a lot of
performance improvements
in the last few releases.
But many more [? are ?]
[? still ?] to come.
We want to do more metric
collection display.
There's a wide variety of
metrics for GameServers
that we want to take advantage
of and display for customers.
Better commercial engine
integration-- right now,
there's lots of people who
are using Unreal and Unity.
But we want to have some
standardized tooling
around that, just to make
life easier for people.
Multi cluster and multi
cluster coordination--
we're looking at
a variety of ways
on how we can do that and make
that easier for people as well.
And it looks like in 1.14, we
have some really nice Windows
hosting.
So we want to look at how
we can support that for game
developers, especially at
development time, where
a lot of game
developers use Windows,
but also supporting it and
production workloads as well.
Do you want talk
about Open Match?
JOSEPH HOLLEY: Yeah, so from
the Open Match standpoint,
Unity has recently
contributed their design
for a longer-lived matching
logic, which is to say,
you can stand up the
matching logic in Kubernetes
and not spin it down in between
the cycles of your matchmakers.
So it makes it very fast to
kick off the matchmaking logic.
It's already there and running.
It'll just spin down
and use very little CPU
whenever it's not necessary.
We're also expanding
metrics and dashboards.
We're actually in the process
of doing another design
iteration on what metrics people
want to get out of Open Match.
So if you're interested
in that, please come
put your comments in the issues
on the GitHub repository.
We are going to be implementing
player and match tracings, so
that you will be able
to pretty easily see
when a player went into your
system, what exactly they did.
What were all the processes
they went through?
Which match making
functions considered them?
Which match they got put in?
Which server they ended up on?
Those should all
be things that you
should be able to trace
through whenever you needed
to debug something, or
troubleshoot something, or just
validate that things
are working the way
that you expect them to.
We want that to all be
built-in and baked-in tools
that we can all
work towards taking
for granted in matchmaking.
And finally, we're
just now getting
the full build chain
setup with make,
which is going to kind of
get all the fancy GitHub
badges around CICD.
Whenever PRs get
merged in, they're
going to need to be validated.
So we are a slightly younger
project than Agones--
we are only on 0.4.
But we have plans on 0.5 soon.
And shout outs to the
team that is working hard
to make that happen.
MARK MANDEL: Fantastic
before we run
away, I would be remiss if I
didn't mention-- if you want
to get Agones cluster
up and running, you
can find Agones on the
Google Cloud Marketplace.
So if you want a
quick test cluster,
so that you can get things
up and running and Agones
installed, you can
basically go boop,
boop, boop-- and that's
literally the noise
it makes-- boop, boop, boop.
So that you can get an
Agones cluster up and running
and put some game servers on
it and start testing it out.
JOSEPH HOLLEY: All right.
MARK MANDEL: Finally, before
we go, where can people
go to learn more?
JOSEPH HOLLEY: So
where to find us--
this has the eventual
URL home that Open Match
is going to live in.
We haven't pushed
to this site yet.
So don't be surprised if you
go look at it on your phone
immediately after the session
if it's not there yet.
But this is going to be live
on the internet in perpetuity.
So by the time you're watching
this on YouTube later,
it's probably already there.
If you need to go find more
details about it immediately,
please go check out GitHub.
Or just Google
search Open Match.
You can also follow
myself on Twitter.
That's my Twitter handle.
MARK MANDEL:
Sweet-- agones.dev--
we have a full site
there with documentation,
which will also link you
to a GitHub repository.
You can follow it on
Twitter @agonesdev.
And you can follow
me on @Neurotic.
I'll also mention that we
both have very active Slack
Channels--
JOSEPH HOLLEY: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: --as
well as Google Groups.
So if you want to get involved,
please come join us in Slack.
We'd love to have
more contributors.
JOSEPH HOLLEY: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: Diversity of impact
and variety of perspectives
is very much appreciated.
JOSEPH HOLLEY:
Yeah, we both think
that open source has a really
bright future in games.
So please come and contribute.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Finally, before we
break into questions,
I just want to mention my
business cards are down here.
So if you think you're going
to have a question maybe
in two months time or in three
weeks time, but not right now,
please feel free to
come up and grab some.
But finally, I thank you
so much for taking the time
to spend with us.
Your time is valuable, so we
appreciate you spending it
with us and listening to us.
But without further ado,
we'll open the floor up
for questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]